das ist so weil erstens momentan erst
mal mobil geimpft wird also in den
altenheimen in den pflegeheimen und in
den kliniken und einige länder haben
zumindest ein impfzentrum aufgemacht wo
dann zum beispiel hier in berlin wo
einzelnes personal aus kliniken dann
geimpft wird aber und dass da nur in dem
mobilen teams liegt natürlich daran dass
wir zu wenig impfstoff zum start haben
das geht fast allen ländern so in
deutschland auch und deswegen bleiben
die mobilen impfzentren erst einmal zu
bis die altenpflegeheime durchgehend
sind und wir genug impfdosen haben um
dann auch tatsächlich in den fünften zu
können das wird in einigen ländern der
fünfte januar sein muss geöffnet wird in
anderen erst ende januar schief gelaufen
das wäre jetzt ebenso wenig impfstoff
haben ja wie viel zeit haben wir also
wir haben es relativ früh und relativ
lange in relativ vielen punkten voll
versammelt das liegt jetzt wirklich
schon monate zurück dass es kaum noch zu
reparieren um es mal durchzugehen wir
haben insgesamt sechs punkte an die zwar
sehr mit worden ist erst mal hat man zu
lange zugeguckt wie die eben nichts
gemacht hat man wollte als eu zusammen
bestellen auch für die armen staaten mit
offen die die selber so eine zulassung
gar nicht machen können
da hat man zu lange abgewartet in berlin
dann hat deutschland eine impf allianz
aufgebaut mit niederlande frankreich und
italien man wollte dann bei astrazeneca
einem hersteller aus großbritannien und
aus schweden extra bestellen
das hat man dann aufgegeben zugunsten
der eu und die kam der lange nicht aus
den pötten dann hat obwohl im sommer
fest stand dass der bayern tech
impfstoff eine granate werden wird dass
dann auch der von moderner funktionieren
muss vom us hersteller die beide mit der
boten-rna arbeiten also ganz neues
verfahren
da hätte man dann sofort bestellen
müssen auch bei moderner extra bestellen
wir sind als deutschland neben der eu
extra bestellen bis man hat zwar
optionen dann gezogen man hat als
deutschland bei und tekna option gemacht
über 30 millionen impfdosen intern aber
man hat vergessen in diesem vertrag
reinzuschreiben wann die geliefert
werden weil man hatte ein parallel quasi
mit der eu mit bestellt aber die eu wird
erst beliefert dann kriegen wir erst
unser kleines kontingent aus der eu bis
bestellung raus und danach wird dann
erste deutschland produziert und dann
klingt das erst mal hätte also sichern
müssen dass wir das zusammen kriegen
dann hätte man bei moderner extra auch
bestellen könnte die eu hat ein bisschen
was bestellt aber wie haben sie parat
bei dem us hersteller der in der schweiz
produziert für europa nicht separat
bestellt obwohl man wusste dass dieser
impfstoff von moderner auch
funktionieren muss und der dann auch
kurz nachdem klar war dass ballack mit
95% rauskommen kann die mit 94 prozent
wirksamkeit raus da ist nichts bestellt
worden
obwohl gedrängt wurde obwohl es von
experten hiess bestellt dienen bloß mit
dann habt ihr schnell mehr weil moderne
hat eine große produktionsanlage in der
schweiz für europa anders als bei und
ehemalige startup wie die produktion von
null auf hundert hofern wovon mussten
hatte moderner schon 50 und da hätte man
also ordern können hat man nicht getan
man hat am 23 dezember erst nachbestellt
macht den ganzen sommer verstreichen
dass man im herbst verstreichen lassen
hat dann erst nach bestellt und dann hat
man einfach stellen nicht erkannt dass
die dass die hersteller früh kleid haben
müssen darüber wieviel bestellungen
eigentlich kommen weiß man früh dass man
viel produzieren soll
dann fährt man die produktion auch hoch
das kann man nicht von heute auf morgen
machen sondern das braucht ein vorlauf
das sind hoch reinräumen den produziert
werden dann musst du ganz spezielle vor
stoffe haben aus denen dann dein produkt
herstellt wir reden hier von rna also
von von genetischen sachen die brauchst
du vorher die müssen spezialhersteller
vorher herstellen wenn das nicht klappt
dann hast du fährst es am anfang mit
einer kleinen produktion los ist
ungeheuer teuer und was also ist eine
kleine produktion und plans dann langsam
den aufbau anstatt gleich los schießen
zu können das ist nicht passiert da hat
man fehler gemacht mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren